- Everyone (beep) loses their mind
once a year when it's pumpkin season.
Literally, (beep) go crazy.
(upbeat acoustic music)
That's pleasant though.
- It's delicious.
- Kinda graham crackery.
- Like a crouton.
- A delicious crouton.
- Super dry!
- Well, yeah it's meant to
be, like, dipped into liquid.
- I would dip this in a
Starbuck's pumpkin spice latte.
- We gotta get in on this.
- Is there that...
- We gotta.
- BRB, becoming pumpkin farmers.
(laughing)
- Looks delicious.
- It looks weird.
- A lot of sugar.
- How come pumpkin automatically implies,
like, 10 times the sugar.
- Yeah, but I don't think it's supposed to
because pumpkins don't have sugar.
They're like squashes right?
Squash the sugar outta pumpkin.
- I hate this word, but I'm gonna use it.
It is kinda moist on the inside.
- I'm now wondering what
pumpkin tastes like.
- Exactly right?
- I'm not really sure
what pumpkin tastes like.
- Why?
- No.
- Dude, it tastes like marmalade.
- Apple sauce, baby food.
- Oh my God, it does
taste like apple sauce.
- I'm not mad at this actually.
- I am.
- I don't know, do I like this?
- I think you may like it.
- Who was the first person
who tried to eat a pumpkin?
This is just too cute from the
get go, I'm telling you that.
- It's adorable, look at these little.
- They are cute.
- Oh, I like this.
I love it.
- At first I was like, "No,"
and then I was like, "Mm,"
and I'm like, "OK."
- The pumpkin tastes
pumpkiny, the tart is tart.
This is how, and it's small,
wow America, good job today.
- Pumpkin beer is something
I think I can get behind of.
- This just made my day.
- I get a little spice at the end.
- Ralph's, Costco, Banana Republic.
(laughing)
- Yeah, that was delicious,
I would drink that bottle.
Oh.
- I think where we are
with pumpkins it's fine,
just, let's just keep
pumpkins at a distance.
- If pumpkins could
just realize that, like,
who they are natural, let alone is enough,
we'd see a revolution.
- It's a lot of hype, and it's
just not that big of a deal,
because you know what's
around the corner, Christmas.
- I think pumpkin's more state of mind.
- I've never had pumpkin pie.
What? I'm sorry.